[Music]
right and action
i need you to pretend that there's
nothing more than an animal
wow
[Music]
i love you too
he's a cute little thing
e.t phone
my favorite part was when he goes
we're celebrating its 40th anniversary
what do you remember from making it food
fights um halloween dress up
it was a very wild and interesting
experience you know you have we had
people in the e.t suits we had a woman
doing his hands we had the ets that were
robots see a pig shirt eats like one
drew was just six years old when she was
cast as gertie at the time she was
actually trying out for the lead role in
poltergeist but steven spielberg who
would later become her godfather felt
this film was a better fit and then your
mouth gets bigger
bigger and screams
without question like
i think steven spielberg is probably one
of my most important relationships it's
been in my life since i was six years
old
he's really the only father figure i've
ever had it proves that you can find
family along the way and it can stay
i love you
how did this role define your career you
know i say i was the mom and 18.
oh
i saw that when i was blah blah blah
let's face it i became
everybody's
[Music]
you look mom
i would not have had a career had i not
worked with kids and dogs
i think
we've probably blown less takes on the
kids than we have on me
dee wallace played the movie single mom
mary
i sat down and went i want to do a movie
that touches people
that
that opens hearts and my agent called
one day and said
you're not going to believe this
steven spielberg just called to offer
you the lead in his new movie
so i didn't audition for et
i knew it was special the minute i read
the script where are you going
to the spaceship spaceship to the
spaceship to the moon
let's talk about uh mr spielberg as we
as we call him respectfully uh
how is he on the set he is a he is he's
a child yeah he's childlike
and
he's so wonderful when he works with the
kids
try once again
action
michael he would play video games with
the kids
on the break he would go out and play
basketball of the kids
on the break he wouldn't come knit with
me
but
[Music]
when we were on set with a rising
director he already had some big hits
under his belt like jaws and raiders of
the lost ark there's never been a goal
to win awards
if it was i really wouldn't be making
the kind of movies i've been making
fun fact harrison ford had a small role
in e.t as the principal but it got cut
some other things you may not know the
one thing drew kept from the set was
this red cowboy hat and she ad-libbed
this line
i don't like his feet
i wanted stephen to be the director of
every movie i did
he was very special and
he treated us like grown-ups
he was always like that's a great idea
use it there try this go for it here he
was the best director any actor young or
old could work with because he brings
out things in you that no other director
does and that's
set me off for like
steven filmed the movie in chronological
order to help the young actors and henry
thomas who played elliott actually had
the director in tears during his
audition well he's mine and he lives
with me and he likes me okay kid you got
the job
fans can re-watch the magic of vt on
demand in digital now as for where the
cast is now henry most recently started
netflix's anthology series the haunting
his on-screen older brother robert
mcnaughton retired from acting and at
one point worked as a mail carrier and
government agent peter coyote who's also
a zen priest went on to star in over 100
shows and movies dee is a healer and has
written seven self-help books and drew's
a mini mogul with her own beauty and
housewares collection her talk show was
just renewed for season three
why do you feel like a movie like et has
lasted the test of time i feel like it
is
such a kind
story
i mean it certainly taught us all who
are making it to be
patient
and loving with the unfamiliar
and to protect those
that are different from us
[Music]
you